hey youtubers it's Charlie so we got our
first look at shocker on the set of
spider-man homecoming so this is gonna
be a breakdown we got to see him in his
full-on gear with the gauntlets so in
the tradition of doing tech based
villains in the Marvel Universe
this is shockers look for spider-man
homecoming now shocker was a tech based
villain in the comics too so it's not as
big a change as say like the vulture
wearing a flight suit instead of being a
metahuman but you get the idea
spider-man mostly has animal-themed
villains you know double thumbs-up from
Deadpool shocker is just one that sounds
very much like the Tinker so I'll be
interested to see how they deal with his
origin story but Boheme woodbine gonna
kick some serious ass probably get a few
upgrades from Tinker during the movie
he's a classic sinister six villain and
unlike a lot of other spider-man
villains doesn't start out hating
spider-man like he doesn't want to kill
spider-man because he just hates him so
much he's just a high school dropout
that's really good with tech makes
himself a pair of gauntlets homemade
gauntlets in the same way that
spider-man made his homemade tech before
he met Iron Man so even though shockers
gonna be way older than spider-man in
this movie you could already see a few
similarities between them like imagine
if spider-man dropped out of high school
because he already had like a certain
level of proficiency with all this stuff
and just decided to use his abilities to
make money instead of being a superhero
that's kind of what happened with
shocker so he drops out of school makes
himself these gauntlets and starts
robbing people so you know great power
great responsibility but eventually he
falls in with villains way later in the
comics he gets major upgrades to his
suits that enabled him to actually shock
spider-man when he gets really close his
name is shocker but he's not actually
shocking spider-man it's more like
concentrated airburst so he's like
punching him from way far away so it's
not quite the same thing as electro
where he throws lightning bolts but
isn't gonna simplify it in the movie a
little bit and he'll be throwing energy
blasts in the same way that Iron Man's
arc reactor enables him to shoot energy
blasts but either way he gets a bunch of
suit upgrades some of them actually end
up coming from hammer industries but
Oscorp sinister six stuff aside I think
that most of the villain crossover will
come via the tinkerer like he'll just be
a villain for hire that's really good
with tech that gives the vulture a bunch
of flight suit upgrades probably helps
shocker out at some
during the movie but we really don't
know how much villain cohesion there's
going to be there's probably gonna be a
little bit but I'm not expecting all the
villains to be standing on screen
together high-fiving each other I don't
think they're gonna go straight to
sinister sakes they want to weave that
in slowly but just like we're gonna see
spider-man evolving over the course of
the film I would expect the same from
the villains so they'll probably face
each other early on spider-man will hand
him his ass then he'll go to ground get
upgrades come back kick some spider butt
so let me know in the comments how much
sinister six do you think they're going
to tease in this movie I'm not expecting
it to be on the level of amazing
spider-man 2 the post-credits of that
where you see like all six of the suits
like you see doc Ock's arms I don't
think it's gonna be that overt we might
hear the names of some other big
spider-man villains but like Norman
Osborn Doc Ock all of them are in there
they will definitely make it out to play
in the movies before the end of this new
spider-man trilogy but that's years away
so I don't think we'll have an idea
where the villains of the next movie are
gonna come till we actually see the
movie itself next year but I am really
excited to see like the Marvel version
of the sinister six like we've seen the
amazing spider-man version and Jamie
Foxx electro was actually one of the
better characters during the Andrew
Garfield era so I think it's only gonna
get better from here but next big
question let me know what's the next
sinister six villain that you want to
see them do in the second spider-man
movie with Tom Holland I would expect
with the rise of Doctor Strange and
mysticism magic in the Marvel Universe
that they would push into mystical
spider-man villains too eventually
so like Mysterio would be another good
person who was an original member of the
sinister six they could do who has some
mystical elements to what he does it's
really all about illusion slate of hand
but remember one of the big problems
with spider-man and mystical villains is
that Mephisto is a really big deal in
bad news you know thumbs down because he
appeared in Silver Surfer for the first
time that's where he debuted he probably
belongs to Fox in the movies so if
they're gonna do Mephisto Spiderman
stuff it's probably gonna go to Dormammu
and that would be like phase 4 so I'm
not expecting any of that stuff to
happen anytime soon we're talking way
down the road but I think they would go
to spider-verse before they went to one
more day so there's still a lot of
mystical really trippy spider-man
stories they could do like if they're
gonna weave silk in
to this universe like any will do her
before we get to Mephisto spider-man
stories beget height and if you didn't
see my last Doctor Strange spider-man
video I made the prediction that going
into phase four like after Avengers
infinity war
Spider Man is gonna be one of their
biggest most important characters not
just in the context of the story but
because he's such a popular character
internationally that if the movie does
really well he only gets more popular
people go crazy for a new spider-man
franchise and he becomes one of those
Robert Downey jr. Ironman level
characters that just gets asses into
seats and movie theaters so he becomes a
huge asset for Marvel and Sony so if you
really like this new spider-man he is
probably going to be all over the place
and the cool thing about phase 4 is that
because they have all these actors
extending their contracts they can
introduce new franchises like Black
Panther Captain Marvel and then just
cameo all the older Avengers in those
movies but I definitely think they'll
keep making Captain America Iron Man
movies eventually I think in making Iron
Man such an important character to
spider-man they're kind of
recontextualizing Tony Stark in the
Marvel Universe that'll give him a new
direction to go with the next movie so
eventually we will see Iron Man 4 but
it'll spin out of some of the stuff
that's happening with Spider Man just
you wait there's gonna be like this
hilarious headline that says Queens
Widow and nephew adopt aging lonely
billionaire just can't wait to see it
but congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner Travis Stephens you win
a $30 Amazon card it's basically for the
value of the Civil War blu-ray so please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details and there is a new round that
starts now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video the Civil War blu-ray is
gonna be dropping pretty soon so I'll
just I'll keep doing the giveaway till
that drops but next video will be Thor
Ragnarok I was gonna do that now but
then this drop so it's like oh my god
new spider-man way you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for the
Ghost Rider agents of shield teaser and
you can click here to learn all about
Justice Lee DC movie characters coming
to the TV
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight